[Música]
cerca de 5 millones de ciudadanos
paraguayos fueron a las urnas en una
jornada electoral que no permitía una
segunda vuelta por lo tanto en el mismo
día fue dado a conocer el nombre del
nuevo presidente de los paraguayos en un
proceso electoral que se mostraba como
reñido en el que hubo pocas propuestas
desinterés por parte de los votantes y
un resultado que para muchos sorprendió
y pues para otros no dos caras de la
moneda el triunfador Santiago Peña
estaba dentro de los dos favoritos a
llevarse la Silla presidencial Esto fue
lo que dijo Santiago Peña el nuevo
presidente de los paraguayos al
declararse triunfador de estos comicios
escuchemos
nuestras diferencias para priorizar las
causas comunes
nes ante todo y sobre todo somos
paraguayos
este tiene que ser el único distintivo
que nos identifique como protagonistas
del Gran proyecto de esta restauración
moral de recuperación económica de
crecimiento inclusivo y de Justicia
social
lo que queda claro es que Paraguay esta
vez no dio un viraje político como si lo
marca la tendencia en la región de
América Latina Pero quién es Santiago
Peña el nuevo presidente que asumirá el
cargo el próximo 15 de agosto por los
próximos cinco años Santiago Peña tiene
44 años es visto por muchos sectores
como parte de una nueva generación de
políticos del tradicional partido
Colorado es economista de formación y
hoy es el nuevo presidente de este país
suramericano Al haber obtenido el 43% de
los votos Ya teniendo cerca del 99% de
los votos escrutados por las autoridades
electorales paraguayas en el pasado Peña
se desempeñó como economista en el fondo
monetario internacional en la ciudad de
Washington en Estados Unidos es ex
ministro de hacienda del gobierno del
expresidente Horacio cartes quien es su
digamos padrino político su campaña
electoral estuvo centrada en propuestas
para revitalizar la economía paraguaya
una campaña con muchas promesas pero con
muy pocas ideas de cómo lograr lo que
está prometiendo Como por ejemplo la
creación de unos 500.000 puestos de
trabajo o también por ejemplo la
reducción de los precios de los
combustibles también combatir la
inseguridad el narcotráfico mejorar el
servicio educativo y el servicio de
salud entre otras tantas promesas de
campaña
en el otro lado del espectro político
estaba Efraín alegre un candidato que
representaba una gran coalición llamada
concertación nacional y buscaba hacer
ese presidente de la alternancia
política en un país dominado como ya lo
decíamos políticamente por el partido
Colorado tras aceptar su derrota alegre
reflexionó sobre el desempeño durante la
campaña escuchemos si bien es cierto el
pueblo paraguayo en su mayoría ha votado
por el cambio
la división
ha hecho que no podamos llegar al
objetivo
de poder producir el cambio que
la mayoría de los paraguayos nos están
solicitando tal y como quedan las cosas
Paraguay le dijo sí al continuismo al
partido Colorado para algunos pues como
lo decía Peña representa una renovación
y un nuevo aire dentro de esa formación
política pero para otros sectores
tienen un poco de temor de que tenga
poca independencia de padrino político
Horacio cartes entonces queda la
pregunta sobre la mesa que tanta
maniobra de gobernabilidad tendrá Peña
Cuáles deben ser las prioridades de su
gobierno Y por qué el cambio político y
la alternancia No tuvieron lugar en
estas elecciones en Paraguay y cómo
manejará este nuevo gobierno las ya
tensas relaciones con Estados Unidos y
con sus padres del mercosur ampliamente
enfocados en acercar a este bloque
suramericano a China hoy en el debate de
France 24 hegemonía colorada pues lo
vamos a analizar y para ello hemos
invitado a Esteban caballero él es
analista político también es docente en
flacso Paraguay él se encuentra en la
ciudad de Asunción y allí También se
encuentra el Doctor Gustavo centrini él
es de politólogo y también es docente en
flacso Paraguay los dos se conectan
desde la capital paraguaya nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de este
debate ustedes ya lo saben pueden dejar
comentarios preguntas a través de las
redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y también en instagram no
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24
todo junto todo pegado y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Esteban en la ciudad de Asunción
Esteban Gracias por estar con nosotros
hoy en el programa en el debate Y
pregunta como Punto de partida fue
sorpresivo Este triunfo de Santiago Peña
cómo lo analice usted bienvenido
Bueno sí bienvenido Muchas gracias más
bien Sí definitivamente tengo que
admitir que fue sorprendente la el
margen de Victoria que tuvo el partido
Colorado en todas las carreras porque
ganó ampliamente en senadores en
diputados
quince de las gobernaciones de los 17
departamentos del país y la presidencia
obviamente verdad no se esperaba una
victoria con esos márgenes de manera que
estamos todos sorprendidos un poco
desilusionados evidentemente con las
encuestas que daban al último momento un
empate técnico Y a partir de ahí se
estaba también observando a una
concertación que había ido ganando en
confianza en seguridad y que
daba pie a que estaban por llegar al
cambio como ellos decían no pero no fue
el caso estamos ahora analizando esa
realidad hay muchos motivos por los
cuales no se dio esa ese empate técnico
que podemos analizar evidentemente no
cuando usted diga es la opinión de
Esteban caballero nuestro primer
invitado del programa da le doy la
palabra ahora al Doctor Gustavo centrini
y también allí en Asunción en la capital
paraguaya Bienvenido al programa Gustavo
gracias por estar con nosotros y la
misma pregunta como Punto de partida fue
un triunfo sorpresivo o dentro de sus
cálculos y su análisis la victoria
colorada era evidente
Muchas gracias por por la invitación el
espacio
creo que fue oportuno lo que dijo de que
para algunos es una sorpresa para otros
no creo que yo
en el mismo momento me siento como
sorprendido por el margen de Victoria
pero no no tan sorprendido por el
resultado
lo que está en juego La incertidumbre
que había cerca de esas de esta
selección realmente tenía mucho que ver
con una intervención y la actuación de
la Embajada de Estados Unidos podemos
desempacar un poco ese punto pero
realmente las sanciones que impuso
contra Horacio cartes
y su capacidad de financiar las campañas
del partido Colorado fue algo que que
hizo mucho menos predecible el resultado
de las lecciones Así que los que
analizamos
De antemano no nos sabíamos que tanta
participación electoral iba a haber qué
tanto se iba a poder activar la
maquinaria del partido Colorado para
movilizar sus bases y en ese sentido no
se sabía calcular qué tan tan probable
era una derrota del partido Colorado y
una victoria de la alianza digo la
concertación Bueno hay varios puntos
para analizar en el programa en esta
jornada post electoral allí en Paraguay
Esteban comienzo preguntándole Por qué
Paraguay si había tantos reclamos a la
administración actual a la
administración del presidente Mario abdo
Benítez también muchos reclamos frente
al partido Colorado a su permanencia en
el poder en muchos casos de corrupción Y
denuncias por qué eligen a un nuevo
presidente pero critican la
administración y la tendencia y el rumbo
que le ha dado el partido Colorado a
Paraguay es porque claramente Santiago
Peña representa ese nuevo aire dentro
del partido o esto es simplemente una
una percepción de los votantes
Mire yo para responder a esa pregunta
siempre digo vamos a poner un poco las
cosas en contexto Usted dijo que el
electorado paraguayo suma más o menos
cuatro millones ochocientos en este
momento y tengo en cuenta que Santiago
Peña gana con un millón doscientos para
redondear votos hay tres millones
ochocientos mil electores que no votaron
por el partido Colorado ya sea porque
eligieron otras opciones o porque
simplemente no participaron en las
elecciones Entonces es muy importante
tener eso en mente cuando hablamos sobre
el comportamiento del electorado ahora
ese millón doscientos que votó por
Santiago Peña es en muchos sentidos el
voto duro algunos lo llaman el voto
cautivo del partido Colorado y que es en
cierto sentido desmenuzable en partes
verdad es decir usted entiende vea que
son más o menos
350.000 empleados públicos muchos de
ellos
afiliados al partido Colorado ya que el
partido ha sido partido estado durante
los últimos setenta años estos 350.000
estoy haciendo cálculos gruesos pero que
vale la pena para el argumento tienen
sus familiares uno dos tres digamos
multipliquemos eso por tres y ya tenemos
ahí un millón cien mil luego están los
proveedores los clientes es decir toda
esa maquinaria de
funcionarios públicos más clientes del
estado más otros elementos fácilmente
llegan a sumar ese voto cautivo ese voto
sólido que tiene el partido Colorado y
que lo llevaba lo ha llevado a varias
victorias electorales ante un universo
relativamente pequeño y el otro factor
muy importante de Por qué se da esa
Victoria es porque los otros se
fragmentaron se dividieron en dos
prácticamente con la emergencia del
tercero en discordia el conocido y
emergente paraguayo entonces ahí está la
la causa digamos de los resultados en
términos de la carrera por decirlo de
algún modo No claro y una una oposición
digámoslo Así que no logró estructurar
que no logró hacer engranaje y Porque
ahí sí las cuentas darían de pronto unos
márgenes muy distintos
Gustavo también hay en Asunción su
percepción su opinión porque ese elige
entonces Esteban nos da un contexto de
sumas y restas pero desde su análisis
por qué se vota por el continuismo
a ver yo creo que lo que coloca Esteban
es súper importante para entender
el resultado en el sentido que que hay
una maquinaria clientelar
que realmente creo que esta estas estos
resultados consolidan lo que los
politólogos llaman un régimen de
autoritarismo competitivo en Paraguay
son 70 años de gobierno de un partido
único interrumpido por solamente cinco
años de un gobierno de oposición
entonces todo esto lo que decías Esteban
de la capacidad de movilizar votantes
estaban en juego Entonces
yo califico este resultado como el fin
de un proceso de fragmentación de de la
oposición y de la izquierda
principalmente que comenzó con el golpe
parlamentario quedo con dio contra ese
gobierno de oposición de Fernando
2012 es decir
hay que tener un poco de contexto
histórico para entender por qué llegaron
a estas lecciones con una una posición
tan fragmentada y que no pudo sumar sus
fuerzas para competir con esa máquina
tan pesada del partido Colorado
Gustavo continuó con usted para
preguntarle por la por la oposición por
esta propuesta esta concertación que
ustedes ya como explican llegó
fragmentada en dos candidatos eso
claramente pues evidencia en que la suma
de votos no le no le favoreció a uno de
los dos para para llegar a un porcentaje
más alto y de pronto hacerse con la
presidencia qué le faltó entonces a esta
oposición para poder haber hecho
engranaje para poder unir fuerzas porque
ya la concertación de por sí
representaba un espectro muy amplio de
la política paraguaya pero que faltó
entonces Más allá de la maquinaria obvia
que tiene el partido colorado que le
faltó a la oposición entonces Gustavo
yo creo que la las respuestas que
justamente le falta coherencia O sea que
que estamos en un país donde los
problemas sociales y económica O sea la
mayoría de la población vive en
condiciones muy muy precarias con muy
poca seguridad en todo sentido seguridad
económica seguridad social
70%
perdón si casi 70% de los trabajadores
trabajan en el sector informal
evidentemente la no sé las condiciones
objetivas en la sociedad
dan como para un castigo al partido al
régimen que durante la historia
paraguaya ha construido
esta esta economía y esta sociedad sin
embargo esa oposición se fragmenta entre
distintas figuras
adoptan
estrategias electorales muy parecidas al
al del partido Colorado en el sentido de
en
de proponer ideas y construir bases
tratan de construir figuras y movilizar
estrategias clientelares y Bueno en
ese cálculo electoral de querer sumarlo
insumable
hay coherencia de Propuesta realmente es
muy difícil convencer a los votantes
romper con una relación clientelar con
el partido explorado y optar por por una
opción diferente y arriesgado de una
coalición que realmente no evidentemente
una fuerza ideológica o coherente
Esteban su opinión sobre esta
fragmentación de la oposición
bien entonces ahí tenemos yo creo un
tema de que si bien se habló de la
concertación que era el instrumento
predilecto para poder ser la alternativa
en la construcción de esa
concertación hubieron algunos problemas
en términos de relacionamiento político
uno de ellos fue que el segundo o tercer
la segunda fuerza de oposición en el
senado que es lo que se llama el frente
guazú o frente grande que es la
izquierda paraguaya
intentó estar en la boleta de
presidencia y vicepresidencia con el
señor Efraín alegre Pero al final no
hubo una negociación exitosa y
Efraín elene escogió a una candidata
para vicepresidenta mujer joven que
venía más bien de la sociedad civil con
un perfil más conservador Y entonces esa
izquierda se dividió y parte que ella
apoyó a Fran y alegre y la otra parte
apoyó a un candidato
conocido como clínicas Acevedo ese tipo
de dinámica se dio también con otros
actores con por ejemplo el mismo Payo
Cuba se intentó
digamos ser protagonista La concertación
no resultó había grupos disidentes
colorados que también aspiraban quizás a
tener una boleta mixta de liberal
Colorado tampoco tuvo éxito y Efraín
alegre también entra la concertación
siendo presidente del partido liberal el
otro partido tradicional pero no
teniendo todo el apoyo de ese partido
pues venía de una interna Donde había
oído una polarización y el grupo llamado
pianista por decirlo de algún modo que
sigue un dirigente llamado blaziano No
quedó muy satisfecho y más bien
con perfil bajo no Entonces todos estos
elementos un poco disonantes en la
construcción de la concertación
propiamente dicho tuvieron su efecto
debilitante a medida que se desarrollaba
la idea de la concertación que además se
limitó a la boleta presidencial
vicepresidencial básicamente muchos
partidos apoyaban esa boleta pero a la
misma tiempo tenían su propia lista de
senadores y diputados aparte no Claro
entonces esos elementos confundieron
también un poco el electorado y mucha
gente no entendían poco Cómo se venía la
mano por decirlo claro no se vendía a
los votantes una oferta política
completa un paquete de presidencia
parlamentarios y otros votos regionales
sino que eran dos escenarios diferentes
Esteban continuó con usted ya hemos
hablado esa división en los partidos de
la oposición y lo que costó conformar
Esa esa concertación nacional como se
llamó esa coalición pero también dentro
del partido Colorado había ciertas
divisiones precisamente por los hechos
recientes que han tocado o han permeado
ese partido por esas denuncias de
Estados Unidos hay muchas críticas
algunos algunos políticos al interior
del partido Pero entonces cómo logra
Santiago Peña consolidar Este triunfo
teniendo un partido con ciertas
divisiones Y si el verdaderamente es ir
representa un nuevo aire Porque como
ustedes dicen la política paraguaya se
ha centrado en la creación de figuras
más que en propuestas él es una figura
en este momento
definitivamente es una figura y yo no sé
si él es el articulador de la unidad o
la unión de los Colorados para las
elecciones del 30 de abril o si es lo
que el propio presidente actual Mario
abdo Benítez dijo sobre el partido
Colorado que es un partido con una gran
vocación de poder y sabían que tenían
que mantenerse Unidos para lograr el
poder y así lo hicieron No se dividieron
puede haber algunas pérdidas pero el
conjunto se mantuvo dentro de ese
esquema Santiago Peña aparece como un
candidato novedoso usted tiene razón es
un hombre joven un Tecno político que
promete cambios y que tiene un perfil
muy distinto al político tradicional
inclusive cuando la gente analiza lo que
es digamos el comportamiento electoral
de jóvenes
parecía que es Santiago Peña traía más
al joven inclusive que el candidato
alegre entonces ahí hay un elemento
importante en su trayectoria Todos
queremos darle no todos pero muchos
queremos darle a Santiago Peña el
beneficio de la duda es decir yo
personalmente diría Ojalá haya más
Santiago Peña y menos Horacio Carlos que
este este joven presidente realmente
logre asentarse por un gabinete con esas
características él dice y podamos
avanzar en las cosas que se pueden
avanzar en el país bueno y en ese deseo
que tiene Esteban en la política
paraguaya se lo traslado a Gustavo en
ese deseo de un presidente que pueda
tener Independencia y gobernar qué tanto
puede estar el desmarcado de su padrino
político Horacio cartes una figura muy
controversial en en la política
paraguaya pero que es quien ha llevado
un poco de la mano a Peña a Este triunfo
también finalmente fue su ministro y
muchos creen que puede cartes ser el
poder detrás de la imagen de Peña puede
ser así
creo que para entender la independencia
que podría tener Santiago Peña en el
gobierno realmente hay que entender De
dónde viene su capital político y bien
como
remarcar es una figura diferente a un
político tradicional del partido
Colorado
tiene una estrategia técnica es más
joven Pero quién quién le trajo al poder
o sea los dos factores son la capacidad
de movilización política de los
caudillos tradicionales del partido
Colorado que fueron los que el día de
las acciones llevaron a los millones de
votantes a los locales de votación Con
promesas mucho más tradicionales sobre
sobre acceso a prebendas a empleo
público
a ese apoyo muy tradicional y muy
particular o personal que dan en los
punteros del partido Colorado y por otro
lado el dinero
de cartas y el grupo
que permitió movilizar todo ese
maquinaria en términos financieros el
día de la elección Entonces él él debe
su capacidad de movilización de votos no
a sus ideas ni su identidad
sino a esos factores eso dicho como en
Paraguay no hay reelección
significa que los incentivos en un
ejecutivo son un poco distintos está un
poco
un poco más libre de pensar la segunda
reelección y pensar en lo que puede
lograr como ejecutivo solo periodo claro
y estamos hablando de política y estamos
hablando de política latinoamericana en
donde cualquier escenario es posible
hemos visto gobiernos en otros países
donde el candidato que gana es
abanderado del presidente que sale y
apenas ASUME la Silla presidencial se
desmarca de la tendencia política que ha
venido marcando el paso en ese país No
sé por mencionar un caso pues conocido
cuando Juan Manuel Santos asumió la
presidencia se desmarcó el presidente
Uribe que era quien le marcaba un poco
su tendencia política y hubo una
confrontación política hay casos
similares ha habido en todos los países
de América Latina Gustavo el 15 de
agosto es la fecha en la que Santiago
Peña ASUME la presidencia por cinco años
no hay reelección en Paraguay son cinco
años en los que la lista de deberes y la
lista de necesidades de Paraguay como
buen país latinoamericano la lista es
larga por donde debe empezar el nuevo
presidente cuál sería el área a
atacar en este nuevo mandato
presidencial
y creo como la base de todo la ejecución
del estado o bueno de buen gobierno es
la base fiscal y es lo más urgente en
Paraguay ahora Paraguay tiene un nivel
de endeudamiento preocupante y la carga
fiscal o dispositiva más baja de la
región creo que solo el 11 el 12% del
pib es recado en términos de impuestos
sino es
suficiente ni para los gastos públicos
básicos en cualquier sociedad o sea es
muy por debajo del promedio en la región
pero con toda la se los pendientes en
términos de política de salud política
educativa política de seguridad social
Es realmente es insuficiente Pero
por otro lado el espacio político que
tendrá este gobierno vinculado con
intereses empresariales
va a ser muy muy poco para aumentar la
recaudación de impuestos entonces ahí
hay como una camisa de fuerza bastante
difícil al inicio de este gobierno
Esteban y cuál sería su lista de
prioridades para este nuevo Gobierno ya
lo mencionábamos algunos puntos
importantes la economía que despegue
finalmente la economía paraguaya después
de El Coby 19 pero los temas sociales en
este país son apremiantes
absolutamente Y ese es un tema
importante porque Santiago Peña viene
justamente de un grupo técnico Pero más
bien ligado al Ministerio de Hacienda y
al Banco Central son un poco los
economistas que construyeron esa
estabilidad macroeconómica del tanto se
habla sobre Paraguay sin embargo tenemos
como decía Gustavo un 65% de
trabajadores en el sector informal sin
absolutamente ninguna protección social
excepto su capacidad de hacer una
apoyada para pagar los gastos de la
salud de los familiares es decir
hay una situación también que desde 2014
se está dando que es una un
estancamiento en la reducción de la
pobreza la pobreza total está en 26% y
aún la línea de pobreza es mi séptima no
Entonces tenemos ahí un problema de
desigualdad y exclusión social que él lo
va a atender o debería atenderlo aún con
su perspectiva más bien neoliberal
haciendo fortaleciendo los programas
sociales muy focalizados que tienen
tecoporá pensión de adulto mayor para
poder evitar realmente que se expanda un
fenómeno que es irónico tenerlo en un
Paraguay que exporta alimentos y me
estoy refiriendo a la inseguridad
alimentaria inclusive el Instituto
Nacional de estadística dice que un 25%
de la población sufre de alguna
inseguridad alimentaria
o severa es decir no está ingiriendo la
cantidad de calorías que debería estar
ingiriendo eso es un tema básico básico
pero que existe en este Paraguay que
puede ser el canasto de alimentos del
mundo como dicen verdad eso para mí es
una prioridad sacar adelante el país y
eliminar esa hambre que está existiendo
en este momento claro antes de dar paso
analizar un poco el tema de las
relaciones internacionales para cerrar
este capítulo de la política paraguaya
Esteban Qué significa otros cinco años
más sin alternancia de partido político
en una no se me atrevo a decir una joven
democracia como la es la paraguaya que
terminó la dictadura en 1989 se puede
considerar que es una una democracia
relativamente joven afecta esto esa
construcción democrática de país afecta
esto los cimientos de alternancia para
el futuro cómo lo ve usted
Bueno yo creo que el hecho de que haya
ganado Santiago Peña
limpiamente te da la Pauta de lo que
dicen respecto a la democracia paraguaya
tiene una democracia electoral bastante
sólida Y eso yo creo que no va a estar
puesta en cuestión ni va a ser matizada
como en otros casos sino que va a
continuar y darle la posibilidad al
electorado a plantear sus ideas ahora
dentro de dos años ya hay elecciones
municipales pero Amén de eso tengamos en
cuenta también que justamente uno de los
temas de democracia digamos que tiene
que ver con la inclusión Social es un
tema pendiente y que no ha sido bien
tratado en todos los gobiernos colorados
que hemos tenido en los últimos años en
las últimas décadas y ese aspecto de la
Democracia que podríamos Llamar la
democracia Social es un gran pendiente
No ahí yo pondría el énfasis en términos
de darle también a la gente
oportunidades para poder trabajar y
participar por ejemplo del Estado Mayor
meritocracia en el en la en la en el
estado darle más oportunidades a gente
de todos los colores no Eso es parte
también de un avance que debería darse
en estos tiempos y no colonizar O seguir
colonizando la función pública como se
ha hecho hasta ahora Claro ya viendo
cuando el espectro político paraguayo
pues es tan amplio Gustavo regreso con
usted para preguntarle por algo que
mencionaba yo en la introducción del
programa Y es que Paraguay se sale de
esa ola de viraje político que ha tenido
la región de América Latina este segundo
aire digamos de la izquierda
latinoamericana Paraguay se mantiene en
su digamos habitual tendencia política
excepto por ese corto gobierno de de
Lugo
Qué dice esto qué dice esto para la
región latinoamericana este país en el
corazón de Suramérica y en medio del
bloque del mercosur en donde su único o
Aliado en tendencia política podemos
decir los Uruguay pero que los otros dos
grandes Brasil Argentina pues marcan una
tendencia completamente diferente
sí creo que una de las dudas muy grandes
del próximo gobierno de Santiago Peñas
serás la política internacional y
relaciones internacionales qué
decisiones
toman en cuanto a su relación con un
Brasil liderado por
Lula ascendiente de nuevo en su rol en
la región y el mundo pero
definitivamente con un liderazgo marcado
por ideas ideológicas bastante distintas
sumaba eso la incertidumbre con el rol
de Estados Unidos en Paraguay claro yo
interpreto la intervención las sanciones
en Paraguay por la Embajada de Estados
Unidos como un intento de dar respaldo a
un liberalismo un neoliberalismo quizá
progresista más alineado con el partido
demócrata que también dentro de Estados
Unidos está
vaciado o sea vaciado por el populismo
de derecha en el mundo está aislado por
una china ascen una Rusia
agresiva entonces una pregunta muy
grande es ya que la embajada apostó en
contra de la candidatura de Santiago
Peña de cierta forma ahora que ganó Cuál
será la relación con Estados Unidos hay
más cartas que la embajada quiere jugar
como pesa
los intereses brasileros con Paraguay en
la relación de Estados Unidos con el
próximo gobierno Yo creo que el área de
política menos definida
en este momento y con los vecinos del
mercosur porque vemos a un mercosur
tratando de acercarse mucho a China y
hay que recordar que Paraguay es uno de
los pocos países en el mundo que no
reconoce a la china continental como el
gobierno legítimo de China sino que
reconoce a Taiwán una isla Pues que está
en disputa constante y es generaciones
entre Washington y Beijing ahí también
tiene otro punto de discordia con sus
vecinos y bueno con china que es
inevitable todo el mundo quiere hacer
negocios con China
sí correcto vamos a dar en términos
domésticos también los intereses ligados
al
agroindustria al modelo de
agroexportación que tiene Paraguay tiene
Ven a China el mercado chino con muchos
interés y es un punto de tensión entre
el partido Colorado que que depende de
cierta forma o sea hasta cierto punto en
apoyo taiwanés para distribuir los
beneficios que hay que mantiene a su
base de política
infancia muchas Obras Públicas que
tienen una retribución importante a
nivel político pero otro otro grupo de
interés bastante importante en mantener
El poder del partido Colorado es el
apoyo de lagro negocio y ahí hay un
interés diferente de relacionarse con
china Esteban y su opinión estas
relaciones internacionales Brasil
mercosur Brasil es muy importante para
para la economía y para bueno Y también
para la política paraguaya pero la
relación con Estados Unidos que siempre
ha sido un país Aliado Y esa atención
que hay con china podrá definir un nuevo
rumbo hasta tratar de romper su relación
con Taiwán y enrutarse con China y
también se me queda otro país por fuera
Venezuela esa relación dentro del
mercosur Sí bueno Empezando por
Venezuela él acaba de hacer
declaraciones de que va a retomar las
relaciones diplomáticas con Venezuela
con el gobierno de maduro rompiendo con
lo que fue lo anterior que fue el tema
del grupo de Lima y el reconocimiento de
guaidó en ese sentido ya se acopla a la
nueva tendencia de cómo tratar a el tema
Venezuela manteniendo digamos los
principios de Derechos Humanos
democracia libertad etcétera Pero
Estableciendo relaciones diplomáticas
con el gobierno de maduro ahora con el
tema de de China Taiwán Paraguay Brasil
Sudamérica etcétera la pregunta que yo
me hago es cuan sostenible es que
Paraguay sea el único país sudamericano
que mantenga una embajada de Taiwán en
el país verdad viviendo como se está
perfilando la relación con china tanto a
nivel del celac como a nivel del intento
de construcción de la integración
Sudamericana de vuelta No liderará
justamente por Brasil que tiene gran
interés en acoplarse o por lo menos
tener una relación orgánica con la
economía china verdad Hasta qué punto
esa situación de Peña o del gobierno que
viene en una región donde está tan
homogenizada la relación con China y no
con Taiwán se puedan mantener esa idea
de la excepcionalidad de de Paraguay
verdad Esa es la teoría o la hipótesis
que tienen actualmente decir Nosotros
somos la excepcionalidad tenemos una
relación de Taiwán somos un país pequeño
Entonces por
que tenemos con Taiwán A lo mejor le
podemos sacar más provecho la relación
de Taiwán que un poco compense nuestro
sacrificio de no relacionarnos con China
de manera más generosa estoy siendo muy
pragmático Yo creo que el pensamiento va
por ese lado vale más hacer eso que
relacionarse con china pero póngale
usted que haya un gran proyecto Regional
de de desarrollo de infraestructuras
como se está viendo ahora con con China
y eso pase por Paraguay de alguna manera
u otra entonces ahí va a haber más
presión de parte de la región Paraguay
alinearte a los otros para poder todos
tener una relación común con china
verdad inclusive si viene una un un país
políticamente más cercano al partido
Colorado ahora con la elección en
Argentina que se viene y que puede ganar
es una una una una una candidata o un
candidato de Juntos por el cambio el
Paraguay ya no va a estar entre progresi
tener un un país liberal también
conservador Si se quiere verdad pero las
situaciones esa es estructural No sí
pues Ah Esteban y a Gustavo centrini
Esteban Caballero en la ciudad de
Asunción les agradezco por este análisis
aprendiendo hoy de política paraguaya
después de este proceso electoral allí
en este país suramericano les agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros y
Haber puesto en perspectiva y el
análisis a toda la audiencia de France
24 ustedes Muchas gracias por la
sintonía En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos haber estado con
nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncel y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan con nosotros
[Música]